keith richards shows up in the
documentary and he talks about his
little sister that being you and he
accepts you
as um a true equal as a songwriter and
his musician
it's so weird because i grew up in a
tiny town with three stop lights and my
vision of how to get out of my town was
through uh fleetwood mac and i mean
initially through carol king through
elton john and james taylor and then the
stones
and and bonnie rate when i saw bonnie
holding a guitar i was like oh
i a girl can do that i can do that and i
loaded up my car i moved to la
and when my first record came out it was
such an oddball record and what was
happening was
seattle and
particularly like um
smashing pumpkins and beck was starting
to break and hole
and i was just an outsider and it was
the stones that kind of plucked me out
of
um being an outsider and said hey
welcome to our
our scene and that was the scene i i
wanted to be in anyway and
always felt like i was born too late you
know that scene with dylan and
um crosby stills and nash and those guys
and i was so lucky to be embraced by
them um and i wouldn't have it any other
way you know it's just been a huge honor
but also the coolest thing ever the
first time the stones called you to
actually
go up on stage with mick jagger
that was around the time of your first
album coming out right you were starting
to really happen
and i can't imagine what that was like
the nerves i know you've described that
you vomited before you went on stage
with mick i vomited all day i was so
terrified and then right before i went
out um bobby keys the great bobby keys
handed me a bottle of tequila and said
um here's a little courage and kind of
shuffled me out and
you know and i literally i can remember
exactly what i was thinking when i was
like
you know six inches from mick's face oh
this is the guy who's
the zipper on sticky you know that i
unzipped on the record you know i mean
you just go back to being that kid who
is
looking at somebody who you looked at on
on the records and i still have that
like i i texted him recently and asked
him if he'd play harp on live with me
because we just redid this
song that we initially sang together and
as i was texting him i was just thinking
holy crap i can't even believe i have
his phone number